cette aventure m'a changé votre vie il y
as presque un an je me suis rendu au
japon en quête de sa l'arcade ufo
catcher bornes mario kart à fléchettes
dance dance revolution tous ces objets
est si rare en france sont dorées s'en
est flambant neuf là bas et ils marchent
bien cela fait maintenant plusieurs mois
que je ne rêve plus que d'une chose il
retournait salut dans le maire n'est
plus un des lots japon pour faire des uv
faux capture allez salut quoi les amis
nous sommes sûrs à cuba catcheur c'est
un site web où nous sommes connectés à
des [ __ ] du fo catcheurs en direct du
japon ont les contrôler à distance pour
tenter de gagner les figurines qu'ils
contiennent du rhin qui vont survie
n'est que je suis à noja pour mars
dernier j'ai chopé peut-être trente
objets dans les infos catcheur petite
image
preuve à l'appui attention il ya de tout
des figurines des peluches et de l'art
mac dans l'air bref ça coûte un euro 90
laisser au lieu de 1 euro japon mais tu
as les frais livraison gratuite je veux
qu'on chope une figurine aujourd'hui au
quai succès pour gagner un [ __ ] de
d'amis beau de pâques ou de figurines
j'en sais rien bref il faut faire tomber
une boule dans ce trou là allez vas-y
première et c'est parti et savait mais
qu'une boule c'est au bout si beau
trophée mondial brasure à tester ces
partis ont mais c'est pas ça pue ça
commence et j'ai regardé les deux pattes
un mec c'est abusé le délai je dois
doser sans même voir ça à fait
scandaleux mais on va jamais gagné un
truc
3 on est en plein dessus as qu aux
[ __ ] de toute façon le vous a vu le
lac du cantal est ce qu'on en a une
bonne valeur bien trop loin avec c'est
possible oui puisqu'on a eu un truc
elle est tombée ou pas elle est tombée
sur le côté [ __ ] oh non on en avait
une c'est tellement dommage à l'oignon
retour on va se ruiner
franchement vous devez être fier de moi
que vous pouvez le voir l'argent des
abonnés passent quand même dans des
trucs importants bombay où j'arrêterai
pas donc on n'a pas gagné un truc qu'on
l'a pas reçue ici dans un studio mais
comme ça je suis bien là non non mais
non mais ça abusé des fois le délai au
[ __ ]
allez allez allez on y croit on y croit
on y croit yamgnane moynier moyen-moyen
molotov
non non la routine mais c'était pas de
ping-pong d'un bon dîner ou fan de la
douille bon dernier à cette machine de
mort deux fois qu'elle est directe à
gauche et un peu de remous il alors ça
la gauche quoi boire zinic un sac à dos
pikachu attend ça c'est quoi comme
machine il faut faire quoi il faut juste
choper le sac et le faire tomber
mercuria garde moyens je jure sur les
grands moyens c'est parti pour être
précis par contre là on est bien on est
bien on est bien on est bien on est
bientôt même au japon devrait pas
refaire tout mais c'est bien ah non mais
là il va se hopu tain je fais de la
merde au maire du coup c'est impossible
les rapproche
sa mission coller ses morts ses morts on
peux plus je les ai collé il ya plus de
place pour que la pince tant fait pour
le sac à dos des déçus rouillard sa
mecque alors ça mec j'en ai fait six
milliards en gros là il faut pousser le
truc à gauche ou à droite
au choix on va voir si je vais réussir
si j'ai réussi je suis un héros
réservation iam est cadre à jouer à je
peux pas jouer c'est réservé que hasnia
même chose là mais tu gagneras une
figurine d'une meuf à la chine a tenté
on est bien on est bien on est bien ça
le pouce ou pas au lapin c'est la grippe
pas du tout c'est les mêmes dulko japon
c'est horrible oh [ __ ] je suis là je
me le fais à la bouger de 1 mm on est
dans la merde allez allez lui car tu vas
bien sûr côté tu l'attirent marron puis
c'est grave président de gagner sur ça
on est bien
je vous jure connaît bien
on est bien on est bien à l'esprit et
dans l'anneau à la douce aux mondiaux on
peut tenter le one piece
allez on y va ouais la grippe bien non
c'est faux je suis sur le mec de la
vraie vie les devant la vitrine voilà
basse bouger il faut graver de ma gueule
mon gars tu as tout filmé en temps et
connard fait la tombe et se plaît au
[ __ ] je me sens bien à qoussaya comme
si l'on était sur la bonne voie
arrête-toi vraiment pas ce que tu vas tu
vas mettre toute l'étude dans la machine
je te vois toi qui détient la salle être
en sueur comme ça parce que je vais
gagner la figurine en ayant nui 10 fois
le prix de ce qu'il faut aux canapés ya
eu un séisme dans la cabine alors devant
se lancer ayant bougé la figurine de 1
mm laissez moi vous dire que si vous
allez au japon en fait quand il voit que
vous êtes étrangers vont être beaucoup
plus sympas avec vous donc rester devant
la machine pendant longtemps ok vous
mettez une pièce vous faites un essai
vous faites en sorte qu'ils vous vois
faire un essai elle est en fait un nom
si vous êtes avec votre copine ça marche
encore mieux parce qu'ils voudront
vraiment que vous un souvenir
inoubliable du japon pour amener vos
autres copains touristes qui vont
dépenser leur argent dans le pays et
puis vous restez devant même si vous
mettez plus ts vous faire genre oh non
même si elle pense bouge pas et puis
soudain vous allez voir les grues dit
wayne ce coup de pouce tempé lait il va
vous la mettre au bord et là tu sais que
ce soir ta copine va être heureuse et va
se gâter va rester avec toi jusqu'à la
fin de ta vie très bien ça m'a saoulé ol
me plaisent à la cette machine me plaît
c'est parti on y va on n'y a pas trop de
lag walla super je pensais pas qu'ils
avaient du lac avec je suis dégoûté en
fait les ufo catcher de base c'est hyper
dur quand il ya du lag
c'est plus et même but turquoise est
impossible je suis en train de faire son
salaire louga au hall a fait la
balançoire c'est de la merde me laver la
balançoire
j'sais pas si je suis content si jude
reese a ici un choc bien plus machos pas
[Musique]
allez on y croit on y croit on y croit à
la main non plus la machine ait l'air
d'un peu moins la guerre il faut que
j'aille au fond du premier round
oui non je me ne s'est pas rassuré ça va
aider satya dessus
les amis il suffit d'un bon lancer on
est devant un seul mot lancé ça résonne
dans la bouteille saas dans la bouteille
du coup certains le boot est celle de la
chance tension la pousse à l'opposé d'un
foulard d'emballer coup j'ai fait une
requête
on va marquer please give me the prize
s'il te plaît donne moi le prix j'essaye
40 fois à ok je suis le mec il à
l'historique des essais c'est possible
qu'il soit sympa on va voir bon alors
c'est avec honneur et ma tante coup
lâche encore un peu plus de tud je le
mets dans le ventre qui brasse de l'air
mon gars j'aimerais trop que le mec
arrive au
[Musique]
j'ai tout celle sur le site pour que le
mail qu'il arrive assez rapidement ces
quelques mois qui joue actuellement
il a tellement pitié de moi c'est
tellement mignon au hockey ce qui doit
se passer mais c'est la wii lancée de
cabine mais c'est le feu il faut se
concentrer c'est la bonne c'est la bonne
c'est la bonne chère bonne musique
classique musique classique c'est la
bonne je le sors j'ai un feeling quand
j'ai un feeling à chaque fois je lai
dans les 18 lancers à venir je peux dire
que le gars il va manger un bon resto ce
soir il va vite et tous ces photos il va
être refait bon je lui ai dit que je
n'avais pas loin puisqu'il ya des la
grande hommes voilà et vu tu vois un
lapin depuis tout à l'heure qui chante
des trucs dans le vide
je pense qu'il va me croira laisse te
plaisent le plus japonais s'te plaît
sevré ohio c'est à dire bonjour le matin
et vu que ça au japon c'est le matin
j'en ai marre
il a mis cette vidéo pour une tournure
inattendue je craque
[Musique]
t
cette impression ah oui vas-y je vais
mettre les coordonnées je veux bien
croire cette figurine à jour dans ce
bureau où va la vendre à la pause est là
et nous rappellera 16 c'est affreux
moment passé pour ce [ __ ] de fo
streaming live au maire puis cech jeu si
tu fumes nicotine aux mondiaux la
recevoir
on va la recevoir il j'avais mis
tellement tune sur le compte qu'on peut
peut-être tenté d'en avoir une autre
c'est un calvaire j'ai envie d'arriver
au modjo le casque coca cola mais qui
n'a jamais rêvé d'un casque du coca cola
noël mon gars c'est incroyable à l'aller
donnez-moi le casque coca cola allez
allez allez au elle aurait pu aux
mondiaux je veux le gaz coca cola mon
gars c'est la nouvelle mode
je le bats situe marne avec des millions
de gens seront que tu varna qu'il arrive
bien refait il arrive j'ai vu le reflet
il est là
[Musique]
mais qu on me l'avait achetée via les
crédits sur le site pour être franc j'ai
pris 300 euros qui lui parce que je
voulais absolument qu'on gagne un truc
monde j'ai mis 5 essais j'ai eu un
casque coca cola quoi bon made in china
et coûte 3 euros en frais mais ses
parents les amis ont surtout dans
quelques semaines pour ouvrir ces colis
ensemble on l'a bien mérité franche
comté
regardez ce que je ramène à la maison
n'est pas bien les marques et arnaques
la ronde et zoom pour que les gens
puissent voir ce que l'or est ce qu'on
n'a pas hâte de voir lukas coca cola
franchement est ce que n'a pas envie
d'être à la mode toujours faire à
l'extérieur intentions plutôt un boxing
c'est incroyable ok alors moi je le vois
au mondial et plein de poussière 1
mondial il est là j'avais tellement
apercevoir ce casque qui coûte 5 euros
dans le commerce mais qui venait revenu
à 10000 euros en contient vous nous
régaler alors là si je puis me permettre
c'est la régalade swag et la belle
figurine [ __ ] aux mondiaux allez là
elle est là c'est incroyable
et voilà la figurine est là ce qui est
bien sic et ben voilà les amis c'était
une très belle arnaque à cette figurine
coûte dans le commerce 15 euros elle
vous est revenu à 100 et le casque eaux
calmes et le casse-cou cas mais est ce
qu'il est bien ah bah non bah non merci
apple quand on recule et c'est bien
c'est bien de retirer le [ __ ] ça passe
boss et la même qualité que les
écouteurs philips que tu achètes à 5
euros à la guerre quand on oublié tes
vrais écouteurs et ben les amis c'est la
fin de cette arnaque conséquent même
amusé on a régalé un japonais je peux
dire que ce soit il invite tous ses
poteaux et stone n'hésitez pas aimé la
vidéo ça vous a plu bien évidemment
n'allez surtout pas sur ce site
parce que c'est de l'arnaqué on aura
joué aux yeux fo voilà on aura mis
tellement de thunes dedans d'ailleurs
que je pourrai pas aller au japon cette
année c'est bien mais c'est comme si
j'étais allé c'est bien à la tête
tranchée ne le portez vous bien sûr tout
le monde